okay before this video begins it's time
for me to flex on you I have the stream
deck mini everyone very nice for those
you don't know this is basically like a
shortcut hotkey function it's super
convenient if you're a youtuber or a
streamer Elgato always making my life
easier so right now for example I have
this button that lets me record with OBS
I literally just press this and I'm no
one recording very nice you can also
turn it into a sound board I only have
one bed
Brad Brad Brad you can basically do
anything it's very nice also obviously
control music there's so many different
things you can do with this send tweets
out right away I have all my most
commonly used apps as hot keys and
websites as well I should not go into
main there right now they are super easy
to set up so many different functions
this thing is great I highly recommend
checking it out and that's it check out
the video now bye okay don't they look
slick so cool Elgato just keeps on
popping out like the best products I
would 100% buying these even if I
weren't sponsored with them they're
really good obviously and they come with
a clamp in the stand so you can adjust
them change the height change the
direction flop them on your desk and bam
you got good lighting in your videos
that's right pretty good plus you'll
save a lot of money if you go with
another brand that I used to have for
this you're just gonna pay way more for
no reason thank you Adam for sponsoring
this video
am i interrupting something here look
under my skirt I can't just lift it up
boy here you know some stuff you just
shouldn't revisit
for obvious reasons nothing has improved
Hey put it on put it on me
bongo cat come on come on give it to me
put it on put it on oh okay the reason
I'm playing this shut up please
hey what up pokemon how you doing anyone
who places that isn't brain dead no are
you no no no no no okay good to meet you
yes ah oh oh hey hey we got younger sis
there it is jungle jungle so let me
become I'm Chung goes oh my god this
changes everything
oh well you sound like a 12 year old
jungle get it right please never I'm
solid ass please guys he's got
unsubscribe no I did I'm banning your
band
I'm sorry no there's no apology am i
interrupting something here my skirt I
can't just lift it up boy here is a
penis run banished run
wait wait you wanna see my penis oh hell
yeah
yes yes sure of course
don't report me why writer write
[Music]
Jesus Christ a good eventually pizza
just abusers its pizza kind what's going
on spider main not much not much not
much that's cool are you doing no I'm
sorry I don't don't mean to interrupt
keep keep doing what you're doing you
got a great ass spider-man you okay
there buddy you all right there buddy
a big chunk is Jesus Christ you never
heard of me my it's the real one you're
going then big chuckles you're probably
my name I gotta stay hidden two-time
ninja I can't just not ninja
no no I get that a lot it's a common
misconception okay
people just say I don't know the ins and
outs autism has become an epidemic who
said that
okay it's time don't worry plastic
surgery can do wonders you'll I'm sure
that you're right I'm about to do it
you're about to do plastic surgery yes
oh my god I'm here blue now oh okay
great you're an anime thought like
everyone else great Hey look there's
another one I never played I Hey whoa
whoa
ha-ah hey hey
Ukraine I do
[Music]
got it Oh what how this bullet I hit it
right in the ass Oh get hello guys what
up bro oh sorry hey hey what are you
looking at you go in the corner you're
fine
sit down sit down all right are you the
murderer no say that again are you the
murderer no cuz I would have killed you
already
oh yeah you would have how because
because there's a knife right here
I can't don't shoot the gun shoot I'm
not shooting anybody
ah
Caterham ace I guess they never miss huh
alright let's freakin do this guy's
everyone have fun and good luck okay
Oh
Oh it's CaptainSparklez my favorite
minecrafter hey man what's up what's up
what's up Oh
it's PewDiePie hell yeah bye everyone
yeah oh oh yeah that's epic I am love
PewDiePie
hey where's Peter fine where did Peter
by go oh oh oh no not 35 feet if I put
on the gun PewDiePie put down the gun
PewDiePie don't do it
I gotta getta brofist from my time
come on my hands come on sing sing bases
on your please okay now they don't like
it if I now you are you sound like the
bridge and then you whinnies don't bully
paid a pyre to do it PewDiePie
hey brah but we're gonna dive to stay
here watch out for the barrels brah hey
no a petabyte hit me up with a broad
face bro yeah yeah
be careful in there you kidding me are
you kidding me you kidding me it sounds
like how dare you oh my god no one
touches you you are the real
that's the real Phoenix is a real pretty
spine there's the real pretty pike
place your hand if you bring it back
who's the real 35 I took my guy you tell
me what happened we're gonna break the
sub-game Jesus Christ yeah we broke it
great you know we broke the Sarah all
right bro it's been a pleasure but I'm
out hope you guys enjoyed that video
smash like if you did I also want to let
you guys know we are accepting
pre-orders for Itsuki the last
collection for the final time okay
it will be one more pre-order and then
it's gone forever I think at least so
only today last chance
check out Sookie link in description bye
bye bye bye